During your travels around the Internet,
you may have bumped into
the term toxic masculinity.
It usually shows up in connection with
particularly abusive male behavior.
So things like harassment, homophobia,
sexism or violent outbursts.
But what does it really
mean? Well, let's find out
now since there tends to be so much
confusion and defensiveness surrounding
these two words, I think we might need
to start off with a really clear example.
You know, something that we
can all agree on. Okay. Yeah,
but honestly, I think he needs his
own video. So maybe something else.
What do you think you're doing?
Okay, that's going to work.
This charming fellow is biff from
the back of the future series.
Hello? Hello? Hello? Hello.
Anybody home? Hello? Hello. Anybody home?
Okay, so let's start with the word
masculinity itself. Very broadly speaking,
masculinity is a set of behaviors and
practices that have traditionally been
associated with men and
manhood in our culture,
and that includes both
positive and negative things.
Toxic masculinity on the other hand is
a loose term that's used to refer to a
subset of those behaviors,
which are harmful or destructive.
It's often used as a sort of shorthand
to describe behaviors linked to
domination,
humiliation and control.
It's marked by things like emotional
detachment and hyper competitiveness.
Fifth, somebody already asked
me to dance. Well, George Mcfly,
I'm going with Calvin Klein. Okay.
Calvin Klein. Nope, it's not okay.
You're going with me. Understand,
get your focus off of me.
When are you going to get it through your
thick skull? Lorraine, you're my girl.
It's also connected to the sexual
objectification of women as well as other
predatory sexual behaviors.
You know, you want me to give it
to you? I'm not that kind of girl.
You are and you just don't know.
It's also linked very closely with
aggression, intimidation and violence.
You want to take a poke at me?
Damn it.
Modifier toxic is used to highlight the
fact that these kinds of behaviors carry
with them some potentially serious
and even deadly consequences.
Much of this type of masculinity
is relational and as such,
it's mostly defined in opposition to
anything culturally associated with women,
which is why toxic masculinity is
driven by this overwhelming fear of
emasculation. That is to say the fear of
being perceived by others as feminine.
And therefore unmanly.
Many of the most popular male heroes and
movies are depicted as engaging in at
least a few of these toxic behaviors.
Well,
it's both play
cause they're the good guys.
They're actions are framed as admirable
displays of strength, power and manhood.
Thank meet Felix lighter. It
looks, say hello to Dan. Hi Dan.
Didn't say goodbye to Phoenix Madden talk.
It's like doc said. I know, I
know. If you put your mind to it,
you can accomplish anything. And even
when those behaviors are not celebrated,
it's often framed as acceptable or normal.
And then excused.
It's just guys being
guys or boys being boys.
Just to make sure there's
no misunderstanding.
I want to make something absolutely clear.
This term is not a condemnation
of men wore manhood because again,
toxic masculinity only refers to a
particular set of harmful actions and
cultural practices.
And none of those behaviors are
inherent or biological traits of men.
There's nothing toxic
about just being a man,
but some men do act in toxic
ways. So, in other words,
toxic masculinity is not
something that men are rather,
it's something that some men do.
All right,
so let's return to our friend biff here.
Now, biff is an obvious buffoon. I mean,
he's a school yard bully.
He's like a cartoon villain.
His actions are easy to
spot and understand is
damaging because really toxic
masculinity is what
defines him as a character.
You heard girls party zone
at every point in back to the future.
There might as well be a giant neon sign
hanging over biffs head that says, Hey,
this is the bad guy.
So that's really easy.
But things are rarely so
clear cuts in the real world.
All kinds of men can participate
in toxic masculinity,
including seemingly normal guys who might
also be nerdy or charming or witty or
intelligent.
Since toxic masculinity is a set of
behaviors and not a biological trait.
The real man who participate or not really
one dimensional character archetypes
like biff, and they usually don't
do all of the things on the list.
Okay,
okay. Well, sometimes they do,
but usually that's not the case.
Yeah,
there's a mistaken impression out
there that toxic masculinity means that
everything about masculinity is somehow
toxic, but that is not the case. In fact,
the term toxic masculinity is used to
very deliberately to try to differentiate
the more damaging or destructive male
behaviors from more positive male
behaviors.
When it comes to this term,
it's really important to understand that
it's used to reinforce the fact that
there are many different
types and formulations of
masculinity or as rw Connell
puts it different masculinities,
and since there are many
ways to practice masculinity,
we as men can choose not to engage in
the more toxic behaviors and instead
choose to pursue more positive, empathetic
and cooperative forms of masculinity.
Now,
we only just scratched the surface here,
but I'll leave some links and resources
in the box below if you want to learn
more.
I hope this video did give you a better
understanding of this term and maybe
help clear up some of the
misunderstandings about it.
If you'd like to see more videos
related to media and manhood,
just hop on over to my patrion page
and help fund the pop culture detective
agency.